Hmm,
among the youngest as the approach
maturity go through a hysterical or
history crisis,
but sometimes their vocation manifests
itself at an earlier age.
The boy runs away into the mountains and
remains there for a week or more feeding
on animals,
which he terrorists to pieces with his
teeth.
He returns to the village filthy
bloodstained,
and it's only after 10 or more days that
have passed that he began to babble
incoherent words.
The strange behavior of future showman's
has not failed to attract the attention
of scholars and from the middle of the
past century,
several attempts have been made to
explain the phenomena as a mental
disorder,
but the problem was wrongly put four.
On the one hand,
it is not true that showman's always are
always have to be neuropathic,
mentally deranged.
On the other hand,
and this is the critical issue,
those among them who had been healed
become shamans precisely because they
had succeeded in becoming cured.
So it was not the descent into this
strange subterranean psychological state
that constitutes the transformation that
makes the showman,
but it's the emergence back out of that
and that's a journey to the underworld
and a and a rebirth.
Right?
And so,
and there's this great book,
this is a great book by a guy named
Henri Ellenberger Shay,
and he was an existential,
a psychoanalyst and philosopher,
and he wrote a book called the discovery
of the unconscious,
which I would highly recommend it.
It's on my list of recommended readings.
It is a great book if you want to know
about the psychoanalytic tradition,
uh,
it's the best introduction there is.
And he discusses Adler and young and
Freud and does a very credible job of
all three but also takes the history of
psychoanalytic thought back three or 400
years before Freud.
And so it's very engaging,
reading and,
and,
and very interesting.
And one of the things Ellenberg shape
points out quite clearly is,
and,
and he associates this to some degree
with the shamanic tradition that both
Freud and young,
young in particular underwent very
intense periods of psychological
disturbance.
Let's say,
and I would say what was happening is
that because they were questioning their
axioms at the most fundamental level,
they were deranging their cognitive and
perceptual structures,
right,
and young was also experimenting with
imaginative techniques,
with visionary techniques which he,
which he did lot and there was a period
of his life where he was having
constant,
a constant stream of visions which you
wrote down in a book called the red
book,
but at the same time he was still
functioning as a psychiatrist and
operating normally in the world and so
people have suggested that what he had
was a psychotic break.
But that's ridiculous because you don't
don't.
That's not how it works,
man.
If you're having a psychotic break,
you,
you're not being an effective
psychiatrist.
Those things do not go together,
especially not for a long period of
time.
And so there,
there's the possibility of extreme
experience without cyclocross
psychopathology.
And so,
um,
and Elena Bursa,
he just,
he says much the same thing about Freud
and about Charles Darwin as well,
who underwent a terrible period of,
of,
of mental
confusion,
I would say,
as a consequence of formulating his
theory of evolution,
which was really hard on him because he
was a,
he was a die hard Christian and he knew
what he knew,
what the implications of his theory
word.
He didn't know what to do about that,
you know,
so it was very,
very hard on him.
So it's quite common for people of
genius to go through an intense crisis,
psychological crisis,
but then resolve that.
And the genius is in the resolution,
right?
The precondition for the genius is the
dissolution in some sense because you
have to be obsessed with a problem.
It has to grip you completely before
you're going to concentrate on it.
So obsessively that you might come up
with a solution.
But it's the people who come up with a
solution that are the prophets in the
Sharmane and so forth and so on and,
and,
and so that's not.
This isn't something that only
characterizes our cultures.
We just don't recognize it in our own
culture properly and,
and that's a problem.
Well,
sometimes we do.
Right?
You remember that in,
in,
in the lion king,
right?
That Rafiki shows up.
He's the chairman.
He,
he,
he brings,
he brings up Simba down that tunnel dark
tunnel.
That's the dark night of the soul.
He has them reflect upon himself and a
pool.
When he reflects upon himself,
deeply sees the reflection of his
father,
then that becomes a thing of cosmic
significance.
And his father appears in the sky just
like God appears to Jacob and basically
tells them that it's time for him to
grow the hell up and to return to the
devastated kingdom and to set it right.
You know,
and so and that's right.
That's exactly right.
I mean,
we live in the devastated kingdom.
That's an eternal truth and it's the
responsibility of the individual to grow
the hell up and to set it right because
when it's devastated and when things are
not in place,
then everyone suffers too much and
that's not good.
And there's no excuse for not doing
something about it because you don't
have anything better to do so.
And even like children's movies tell you
this.